cuando en abril del 2020 conversamos con
virginia esta responsable en
comunicación de parís ella pensaba haber
vencido al hobbit sin embargo la misma
noche de nuestra entrevista a la fiebre
volvió beer in y descubrió que padecía
de ccoo bit largo es decir un hobbit con
recaída zenden tuve fiebre muy fuerte
durante varios días y sólo sentía dolor
no tenía ninguna parte de mi cuerpo que
no me doliera a la luz esa noche pensé
que potencialmente no me iba a despertar
al día siguiente pero no no
si se es violento yo lo tenía que
retomar el combate con un corazón y
mente débiles vamos a la civil y fax o
no
el golpe fue sobre todo psicológico
virgin y perdió el cabello a causa del
estrés como su organismo estaba débil a
comienzos de julio desarrolló una
infección estomacal entonces decidió
cambiar de vida y mudarse a la periferia
de parís
yo necesitaba que hubiera menos gente yo
estaba en un lugar muy urbano con gran
densidad y necesitaba eso de encontrar
verdaderamente la naturaleza poder
respirar porque esa fue mi primera
palabra del año 2020 respirar fue
complicado poco a poco bien y recupera
su vida de antes y deja atrás el miedo a
la enfermedad la vacunación ha
despertado en ella la esperanza
a mí con la segunda inyección nadie me
asegura que no voy a volver a vivir lo
que viví
y eso no es algo que pueda ignorar hoy
no estoy con gente que no respeta los
gestos barrera y muy tampoco al interior
de los restaurantes aunque ya reabrieron
jugada de que el que ruge y
evidentemente no beso a la gente
y del sitio un primer beso desde el
inicio de la pandemia fue para su mamá
el pasado 30 de mayo día de la madre en
francia ella también está vacunada